the brothers are both very strong
they're resilient and they're holding up
but obviously the conditions are not
good they're in a Romanian jail cell and
they've been detained for a very lengthy
period at this point they have limited
access to their attorneys um it's it's
not a good condition for them
you've obviously as far as sorry please
finish
I was just gonna I was gonna say to your
second point
their controversial public figures but
that's not a crime and at this point we
have not been provided any proof that
they've committed any crimes nor have
they even been charged so I would ask
that people presume them innocent as
they are